بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله
والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
اما بعد
يقول الحافظ النووي رحمه الله تعالى
في كتابه رياض الصالحين في باب الصبر
وعن عائشه رضي الله عنها
انها سالت رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
عن الطاعون
فاخبرها انه كان عذابا يبعثه الله تعالى
على من يشاء
فجعله الله تعالى رحمه للمؤمنين
فليس من عبد يقع في الطاعون فيمكث في بلده
صابرا محتسبا
يعلم انه لا يصيبه الا ما كتب الله له
الا كان له مثل اجر الشهيد رواه البخاري
كين الرياض الصالحين
الحافظ النووي رحمه الله
عائشه رضي الله عنها
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
طاعون الطاعون
صلى الله عليه وسلم حديث
the black or the
‏this pl which
actually wiped out much of Europe
and
spreads very quickly
kills
very indiscrimin
now
she asked the prophet
about the what does that
عائشه سالت النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم عن
الطاعون
صلى الله عليه وسلم
الله سبحانه وتالى
‏andmin
something like
that spreads in are it is going to take
with it women and children and elderly
and evil and good people and wicked and
all the
عائشه رضي الله عنها
sitation
[Silence]
‏and what
the prop
said
that
the
is
a punishment
‏from Allah
that he sends upon
whomever he chooses from his creation
simultaneously Allah has made this pl a
mercy for the believer
how is that so here we have a pl
everyone seems to die the same kind of
death yet what appears to be the same is
very
الله سبحانه وتالى
is mercy and
kind of person it is what their
intentions are and what
صلى الله عليه وسلم
فليس من عبد
يقع في الطاعون يعني يقع في الطاعون او
يكون في مكان فيه الطاعون
و
يحبس مع الطاعون
فيمكث في بلده يعني بلد الطاعون
صابرا محتسبا
ثم شرح الصبر والاحتساب فقال يعلم انه لا
يصيبه الا ما كتب الله له
الا كان له مثل اجر الشهيد
الله
findead
inite of himself
himself and there placee
‏and hopeful
الله
inev
only what
is what is come
is to afflict him
‏numberful
with
the knowledge and
nothingcept
you know this is
no matter what you must get if you are
الله
[Silence]
الامام البخاري رحمه الله نسال الله
سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده ان يغفر
لنا وان يفقهنا في ديننا وان
يلهمنا صبرا على طلب علم ديننا نساله
سبحانه وتعالى ان يعلمنا من وحيه ومن نصوص
ص كتابه وسنه نبيه ما جهلنا وان يذكرنا
من نصوصهما ما نسينا وان يعلمنا الحكمه
منها اللهم امين وصل اللهم وسلم على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله
رب العالمين
السلام